- We are Ficus and Fern.
That's Fern.
- And that's Ficus.
This is,
- [Both] Best Dressed Fest.
- Last I checked,
there was only room at Coachella
for one celestial goddess.
And you, sir, are not Rihanna.
- Don't try this at home.
You'll end up looking less
like a sexy disco ball
and more like a
freaky glitter ghost.
- Literal garbage.
- This scarlet harlot
is stealing the show
with her fiery
throwback tracksuit,
really channeling JLo here.
- Making this queen the
hottest Jenny on the block.
A must do.
(upbeat music)
(Ficus screams)
She looks like a haunted doll.
And who did her makeup,
Annabelle from The Conjuring?
- She's like the
duchess of Candy Kingdom
with a gingersnap
cookie for a hat.
100%, please don't.
- Love this.
David Bowie on vacation.
- More like Tilda
Swinton at home.
- And now, for
definitely do not.
- Definitely do not.
- [Both] Appropriate.
- Culturally.
Quite simple.
- Just stop doing it.
- We hope this helped enlighten
your future trendy selves.
Dress well, and see
you at Clusterfest.